Wisst ihr was? Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Sag ich euch jetzt mal was.
Ich muss bloß erstmal laden. Auflade.
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf diesen krassen, geilen PC-Port.
Wir spielen jetzt Battlefield 3.
Ich weiß Passwort für meine E-Account nicht mehr.
Lol.
So, erstmal Battlelog versuchen einzuloggen.
Aha, funktioniert.
So, ich sag euch jetzt was.
Jetzt.
So.
So, zack.
Game Capture.
So Leute.
Wer Bock hat Battlefield zu spielen,
schaut mit Battlefield 3.
Hat der Patrick an den eingerichtet.
The Game 402.
Wir spielen jetzt eine Runde Battlefield 3.
Ich hab jetzt keinen Bock mehr auf dieses verbuggte Game von Call of Duty.
Das geht mir auf den Sack.
Es kann doch nicht sein, dass das Game alle 5 Minuten mal abscheißt.
Oder man nicht raustappen darf oder sonst was.
Also wer will, kommt einfach auf meinen Battlefield-Server.
Ich selbst kann mich grad anscheinend auch nicht einloggen.
Okay.
Ja.
Ah, jetzt startet's. Sehr schön.
Game Capture. Battlefield 3.
Easy life.
Ja.
Gut.
Wie viele, wie viele Bildschirme hast du?
Ähm, zwei.
Edit.
Game.
Battlefield.
Edit mal ein Game, was nicht abscheißt.
Battlefield 3.
Ende mit dem Titel mal etwas Aussagekräftiges.
So, spielen wir eine Runde Battlefield.
Go, go.
Also wer will, ähm, ich poste den Link zum Server mal im Chat.
Ja, Cod-Session vorbei, Game crasht.
Geht mir auf den Sack.
Kein Bock mehr.
Ich bring jetzt den Bot nochmal bei, dass der alle 5 Minuten wieder meinen Server spammt, dass das, dass man's auch findet.
Wie kommst du zum neuen Cod?
Das läuft grad im Beta.
Also wenn wir den Server noch irgendwie voll kriegen, spielen wir jetzt noch ein paar Runden Battlefield.
Okay.
Game läuft halt wenigstens auch mal.
Der, der Witz ist halt, ne, draw, ne, wie ging das?
Draw FPS, ne, äh, fuck, äh, list.
Render.
Draw FPS 1.
Also man muss ja sagen, Battlefield 1 ist schon ein bisschen älter.
Aber rein optisch sieht das mindestens mal genau so gut aus, wie das neue Call of Duty läuft mit 144 FPS.
Und funktioniert einfach und stürzt nicht ab.
Also wir können ja mal gucken, ob wir den Server voll kriegen.
Grad mal die Server-Konsole aufmachen.
Jetzt haben wir irgendwie...
Laut, laut Server-Browser sind drei Leute drauf.
In-Game sind keine drauf.
Was auch immer.
Und außerdem habe ich mega Hunger.
Hat dir die geile Cod-Beta gefallen?
Das hat mir Spaß gemacht, ja.
Tatsächlich, es hat mir wirklich Spaß gemacht.
Die Sache ist, dass der PC-Port so unter aller Sau ist,
dass er einfach nicht ordentlich spielbar ist.
Ich glaube, mir ist noch kein Game innerhalb von einer Gaming-Session so oft abgekackt wie das neue Cod.
Da war Battlefield 4 beim Release ja nix dagegen.
Ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, mein Game zeigt Mist an.
Da sind angeblich vier Leute drauf, ne?
Fünf Leute sind drauf, aber ich sehe nichts.
But why?
Fuck das?
Sogar Metal-Warfighter war besser.
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Außerdem...
Haha, Hans, ich wollte es gerade sagen.
Außerdem habe ich nur bei Battle of Order besser gesehen, dass die Gegner durch den Boden teleportieren.
Ne, Audiobug hatte ich nicht.
Vielleicht bist du auf dem falschen Server.
Ne, bin ich nicht.
Ich bin auf meinem Server.
Angeblich sind wieder vier Leute drauf, aber ich sehe nichts.
Leute, warum sehe ich euch nicht im Team?
Aber ich sehe euch in der Server-Konsole.
Habt ihr noch kein Team ausgewählt?
Kann das sein?
Ah, jetzt.
Jetzt sehe ich Leute.
Ja, auf Leute, kommt drauf, was losgehen kann.
Ich spiele alleine, weil ich warte, dass Leute auf den Server kommen.
Wir haben das Game ja erst vor drei, vier Minuten angemacht.
Pschuuu.
Versuchen wir mal, John.
Hast du Punkbuster installiert, Morris?
Wobei, das wirst du sehen, da gibt es eine Fehlermeldung.
Ja.
Ich fand das neue Call of Duty wirklich nicht übel.
Also Gameplay-technisch vom Waffenhandling her hat mir das schon ganz gut gefallen.
Aber die Stabilität und die Menüs und der PC-Port, das ist einfach wieder grausam schlecht.
Das sieht schlecht aus.
Hey, Panzer geht kaputt.
Warum?
Panzer soll nicht kaputt gehen.
Jetzt sind wir angeblich schon fünf Leute auf dem Server.
Joint aber nicht.
Okay, ja, keine Ahnung.
Also am Server liegt es nicht.
Für mich ist Battlefield 3 übrigens immer noch ein Beispiel für ein Game mit richtig gutem Sound.
Was hältst du davon, dass bei Fortnite aus Versehen Crossplay aktiviert war?
Habe ich nichts von mitgekriegt, erzähl mal.
Ist Fortnite
nicht dieses Zombie-Modus-Game, wo sie dann gesagt haben, wir machen jetzt Battle-Royale rein, weil PUBG so erfolgreich ist?
Ach, PS4 kommt mit Xbox One zu sein.
Das ist gut.
Das finde ich gut.
Ja, Crossplay von Konsole zu Konsole ist gut.
Aber Crossplay zwischen Konsole und PC ist halt Fail.
Weil halt einfach die Leute auf der Konsole auf die Fresse kriegen, ne?
Weil man einfach nicht mit Maus...
Beziehungsweise mit Controller gegen Maus-Tastatur anstinken kann mit Aim-Technisch.
Geht halt einfach nicht.
Es gab ja mal diesen Test von Microsoft mit Halo damals, wo sie gesagt haben, ja, wir wollen Halo Crossplay und alles machen.
Da haben sie ja mal getestet.
So die richtig krassen Halo-Pros auf der Xbox gegen mittelmäßige Spieler auf dem PC, Aiming-Technisch.
Und die Pros haben halt einfach nur richtig auf die Fresse gekriegt.
Einfach nur, weil Maus-Tastatur besser ist.
Was Aim anbelangt.
Kann man, muss man nicht diskutieren.
Ist einfach so.
Deswegen finde ich Crossplay zwischen Konsole, finde ich das super.
Also Crossplay zwischen, meinetwegen sogar Switch.
Switch, PS4, Xbox.
Ich hätte dich schon vor 5 Minuten killen können.
Kennst du noch mein PC-Problem von vorher, dass du hast vergessen zu sagen, dass du ein Laptop hast anstatt ein Desktop-PC?
Nein, Laptop ist immer schwierig was dran zu machen.
Da kommt man ja meistens gar nicht richtig ran.
So, auf geht's.
Ja, Crossplay Forza.
Forza ist ja auch ein Rennspiel.
Da geht es jetzt nicht irgendwie um Aimen mit Controller gegen Tastatur, äh, mit Controller gegen Maus.
Rennspiele, würde ich sagen, hat man sogar mit dem Controller ein bisschen Vorteil gegen Tastatur.
Wobei man sich ja dann einfach einen PC-Controller anschließen kann.
Oder auch ein Lenkrad oder so.
Moment mal, ich sehe meinen eigenen Stream nicht mehr.
Was ist da los?
Doch, funktioniert.
Ja, ja, ich kann mich schon noch dran erinnern.
W, W, P, D, D.
Aber kann ich dir leider nicht mehr helfen.
So, von...
Weil ich weiß, dass es mit einem Notebook nicht stimmt.
Da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Beste Wiederbelebung ever.
Jetzt erst mal wieder ungewöhnt von diesem Call of Duty Zeug.
Zu einem ordentlichen Game.
Ich hab Hunger.
Muss was fressen.
Dachte, du wärst cool und kennst dich damit aus.
So, ja.
Ja, leider ist es durch Handauflegen nicht getan, ne?
Da kann man mit dem Rebound halt nichts machen.
Red Splits.
Der lebt noch, ne?
Ah, ne, das dauert nicht.
Ich dachte, der lebt noch.
Ja, W, W, P, D.
Was willst du denn, dass ich mache?
Ich kann von hier an deinem Notebook nichts machen.
Ich hab dir vorhin meine Meinung dazu schon gesagt.
Woran ich denke, dass es liegt.
Ähm, jetzt hast du gesagt, du hast ein Notebook.
Okay, aber was soll ich denn machen?
Alter.
Also, mit dem Notebook kannst du wahrscheinlich...
eh nicht viel dran machen, wenn das kaputt ist.
Du kommst ja an die Teile nicht dran.
Boah.
Du sollst erst mal wieder in das Game reinkommen.
Ja.
Schon genug von Kot, ja.
Reicht.
Game ist immer wieder gecrashed die ganze Zeit.
Und was heißt immer wieder die ganze Zeit?
Es war ja quasi, es ist permanent gecrashed.
Es war ein einziger Crash.
Hier ist Superposition.
Kann man für alle ownen.
Pschu, pschu, wiu, wiu.
Hoffentlich wird der Server jetzt ein bisschen voller, wenn...
wenn wir im...
im Server-Browser ein bisschen steigen,
wegen Play-Account.
Oh.
Das Game ruckelt?
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Oh, fuck.
Hat geruckelt.
Battlefield 3 ruckelt eigentlich nie.
Fuck, was war nochmal Granate werfen?
Okay.
Während wir hier rumliegen,
werden gerade alle M-Comps gelegt.
Ah, fuck.
Ich dachte, er ist weg.
Aber wie einfach alle M-Comps hochgehen
in der Zwischenzeit.
Easy.
Wir müssen aufpassen, dass die uns nicht schrecken.
Und vorne.
Okay, wo ist hier was?
Du kannst nicht an einer Ecke stehen, das stimmt.
Mal gucken, ob das Timing passt.
Komm, komm.
Geh auf, Map.
Fuck.
Nein!
Das war echt eine Sekunde zu früh.
Oh.
Fuck my life.
Das ruckelt?
Das Game ruckelt?
Da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Battlefield 3 ruckelt nie?
Battlefield kann gar nicht ruckeln.
Boom.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ich muss mir gleich was zu essen holen.
Die werden jetzt geschreckt da drüben.
Der Hans.
Jetzt aber.
Jetzt müsste das klappen.
Vielleicht soll ich mal mein PC neu starten,
wenn sogar Battlefield ruckelt.
Vielleicht hat das neue Call of Duty einfach
komplett PC gereckt.
Zerstört.
Quasi, wenn man einmal eingeloggt war
und Call of Duty gespielt hat,
dann muss man PC neu starten,
dass es wieder rausgeht.
Ah, fuck.
Nach Restart war wieder alles okay.
Ernsthaft jetzt?
Das wäre aber ganz schöner Fail.
Das ist ja schon fast Sabotage.
Moment, wir haben eine scheiß Perk-Auswahl.
Das ist ja schon fast Sabotage dann.
Können wir das jetzt mal legen?
Das ruckelt? Ernsthaft?
Das Game ruckelt?
Kann nur am Call of Duty liegen.
Aber der Server wird jetzt langsam voll.
Ist gut.
Wir können noch ein paar ordentliche Runden spielen.
Ich minimiere mal alles im Hintergrund.
Bringt das ja was.
Brings.
Server.
Go, go.
So ein paar ordentliche Runden haben.
Sibaro, wolltest du nicht mitspielen?
Hallo, Tommy.
Max, hast du schon mal mit HTML und CSS
programmiert?
Ja.
Wobei es da jetzt wieder klugscheißer gibt,
die sagen, dass man mit HTML und CSS
nicht programmieren kann.
Aber das sehe ich nicht so schlimm.
Das sehe ich nicht so eng.
Ich finde, man kann das
als Programmieren bezeichnen.
Ich sag's doch, ne?
Haben wir schon zwei Kandidaten
im Chat gerade wieder.
Was ist deine Meinung zur Cod, Peter?
Macht Spaß.
Aber jedes neue Cod macht Spaß.
PC-Port ist scheiße.
Ja.
Scheiße.
Einfach
scheiße.
Und meine Position ist auch scheiße.
Es kann nicht sein,
dass Battlefield ruckelt,
nur weil ich Call of Duty
gespielt habe auf dem Rechner,
bis ich neu starte. Hallo?
The fuck?
Was ist da los?
Ich wusste das ja.
Ich muss aufpassen, dass
ich von der anderen Seite geownt werde.
Oh Mann.
Das ist so typisch im Battlefield.
M-Kong-Gecampe.
Einfach mal sinnlos...
Oh fuck, ich hab keine Munition.
Haben wir noch Munition, Leute, irgendwo hier?
M16, jawoll.
Jetzt wird's op.
Und Smoke.
Eigentlich sollten wir nicht rauspushen.
Ist keine gute Idee.
Die gehen jetzt zu A.
Ich wette mit euch, die gehen zu A.
Ich wusste es nicht.
Gehen wir mal rüber, go, go.
Achtung, ich diffuse weiter.
Ah, durchgedrückt.
Kriegen wir noch einen Retz.
Jawoll.
Wo sind wir?
Op-Waffe.
Server wird langsam voll.
Ich bleib hier mal bei A auf der Seite.
Da kann man nämlich auch wunderbar
rüber in Gang ballern.
Ja, ich geh mal rüber.
Ich geh mal auf die andere Seite gucken.
So wie ich die kenne,
ich klapper die Gegner.
Ja, ja, ja, ich dachte schon,
dass ihr hier rüberkommt.
Da ist er, da ist er.
Zweimal Trick 17.
Fuck, gedacht.
Hat er mitgedacht.
Da hat er mitgedacht.
Oh.
Wie viele, wie viele.
Cheap baited.
Elmo, richtig cheap baited war das.
Mega cheap baited.
Haben wir?
Fuck.
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Dies hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ihns klappt nicht.
Oh, das ist wichtig.
Das muss ich enablen, da hast du recht.
Ganz, ganz wichtig,
dass ich das enable.
Ja, ja, scheiße.
Wenn wir hier OP-Position einnehmen.
Hallo?
Game, lass mich doch da hochklettern.
Warum rennt ihr raus?
Lass doch hier defenden.
Warum geht ihr raus?
Hier drin ist es doch viel einfacher.
Komm rein.
Komm her.
Kommt her, kommt her.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, mit der Shotgun.
So macht man das.
Das Ding ist auch wirklich schwer.
Oh, ich glaub, ich kann immer länger spielen.
Ich muss jetzt was futtern.
Ich hab so übertrieben Hunger.
Aber ich musste jetzt was spielen.
Ich musste noch nach dieser Call of Duty PC-Port-Kacke,
musste jetzt noch eine Runde Battlefield spielen.
In your face.
Social Eating.
Ich hatte eigentlich jetzt nicht vor,
am Rechner zu essen.
Unsere Perks sind übrigens kacke, Leute.
Camper.
Ja, ein bisschen campen gehört dazu.
Come and get your medkit.
Ich kann das an der Standpanzer hören.
Ja, ich höre da einen Panzer.
Ich höre da einen Panzer.
Enemy tank spotted.
Over.
Come here.
Da steht jetzt der andere, steht um die Ecke
und wartet, dass ich rauspusche.
Hey, doch nicht?
Hätte ich jetzt gedacht.
Abstand von der Wand halten.
Ich muss mal gucken, dass jetzt hier nichts
über den langen Mittelgang kommt.
Wird mein Panzer kaputt?
So.
Der Panzer lebt immer noch.
Fuck.
Nee, das war der Hans.
Das war gar nicht der Panzer.
Ich muss spawnen.
Irgendetwas, was den Panzer kaputt machen kann.
Den Panzer nicht kaputt kriegen.
Einmal direkt.
Nicht B alleine lassen, Leute.
Nicht B alleine lassen.
Jetzt gehen sie nämlich ran.
Fuck.
Oh.
Hans der Panzer.
Oh, ich hab Hunger.
Ich hab Hunger.
Jebaited.
Übertrieben Hunger.
Es ruckelt.
Das liegt daran, dass ich vorher Call of Duty gespielt habe.
Anders kann ich mir das dann erklären.
Es ruckelt nie.
Nie.
Kriegen wir aber auf den Sack.
Kannst du mal voll vergessen.
Moment, wo steht der eigentlich mit dem Panzer?
Scheiß auf den Panzer.
Wir können nicht auf den Panzer scheißen.
Auf den Panzer scheißen, gehen wir auf den Sack.
Aber wir müssen mal in die Mitte gucken.
Der Typ weiß schon mal, wie man Panzer fährt.
Der ist hinter dem Stein.
Jetzt müssen wir mal umswitchen auf was ordentliches wieder.
Entschuldigung.
Da kommt wieder ein Panzer.
No.
Boah, was ging dem Panzer?
Flankerino.
No.
Wie stehst du zur Cod, Peter?
Ja.
Es ist ein neues Cod.
Es macht Spaß.
Das Problem ist, der PC-Port ist einfach mal richtig abgefuckt.
Einfach komplett für den Arsch.
Aber komplett für den Arsch.
Crasht alle paar Minuten.
Und sowas, ne?
Also, PC-Menüs sind scheiße.
Also nahezu unspielbar.
Auf dem PC.
Warum hat er es nicht wiederbelebt?
Ja gut, es gibt bestimmt genug,
bei denen es gut läuft.
Aber bei mir, ja, hier,
nachweislich,
nicht.
Was ist denn das?
Sack bei mir.
Das ist doch scheiße.
Das ist doch scheiße zu abfarmen, Leute.
Sack, so lässt es sich abfarmen.
Hehehe.
Die Grafik ist schlechter, finde ich.
Die Grafik ist fast schlechter.
Als MW2.
Beziehungsweise, ähm,
die Grafik ist schlechter als Battlefield.
Und es läuft...
Krass!
He! Wo waren die Gegner jetzt?
Vor allem,
es läuft schlecht.
Wasser habe ich mir noch nie angeguckt.
Boah.
So eine geile Flank hier.
Aber ja.
Wenn man da rauspushen könnte...
Ja, das Game sieht wirklich nicht gut aus.
Also, links hier.
Oh mein Gott.
Sieht nicht gut aus.
Ich habe es ja schon auf mittel gestellt.
Oder auf niedrig?
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe es schon runtergestellt,
die Grafik. Es lief immer noch schlecht.
Und vor allem, wenn man sich die Handschuhe angeguckt hat
und sowas. Das sah einfach nur
erfreulich aus.
Oh, wir haben den Panzer. Wir haben den Panzer geklaut.
Komm her, steig ein.
Steig ein.
Du musst einsteigen.
Du brauchst deinem Geschütz.
Warten, bis das Ding gerettet ist.
Die kommen bestimmt über die Straße, klar.
Die denken, ich gucke nicht nach hinten.
Haha! Aber da haben sie sich getäuscht.
Du könntest ruhig wieder
auf die Straße zurückfahren.
Das Beste ist die zweiläufige Shotgun.
Die soll laut rennen.
Scheiße sein.
Und was richtig OP ist,
ist halt
Pump-Action-Shotgun
mit
Brandmunition.
Aber die doppelläufige habe ich
noch nicht ausprobiert.
Da oben ist er. Ich habe dich gesehen.
Streck den Kopf raus.
Da sieht man, wie OP es ist,
wenn man den Gegner in den Panzer klaut.
Jojo, du musst alles lesen, Max.
Stimmt das nicht,
was die geschrieben haben?
Was ist mit den Shotguns?
Also ich habe nur die Pump-Action-Shotgun
ausprobiert.
Und die Pump-Action-Shotgun
war halt maßlos OP.
Ah, ja 80 bis 90
ist halt doof für eine Waffe,
die nicht so langsam
nachlädt.
Ich kann nicht alles lesen.
Ich muss spielen dabei.
Und ich muss was futtern.
Ich habe so Hunger.
Wie lange soll das hier eigentlich noch gehen?
Wir müssen zu A.
Da ist nichts mehr.
Ach, deswegen ist nichts mehr an A.
Weil unsere Leute
den Eingang bekämpfen.
Das habe ich jetzt so nicht gesehen
auf der Mini-Web.
Fast PS3.
Der wird uns gleich von hinten
beglücken, der hier.
Na?
Also die Beta hat
in jedem Fall mich
nicht dazu gebracht, jetzt, dass ich mir
das Game vorbestelle oder
wahrscheinlich sogar nicht verkaufe.
Ja, also
ich finde auch, das Game hat an sich
schon Spaß gemacht, aber der Port war halt
einfach so kacke.
Kann ich den mal treffen, den Typ?
Nein.
Ich werde da gerne noch reingeschossen.
Ja, klar
ist es wieder nur Call of Duty
in einem anderen Gewand. Aber was anderes erwartet
man ja auch nicht.
Ich würde aber erwarten, dass das
wenigstens läuft.
Und das Game läuft ja nicht mal.
Okay, fünf Minuten läuft es.
Dann kackt es ab.
Panzer hin und her, Gefahr.
Wie OP das ist, wenn man
den Gegner mit dem Panzer klaut, ha?
Ähm.
Das ist ein bisschen
eine enge Ecke.
Bald haben wir das Dorf hier kaputt.
Und dann kann ich ganz schnell
mal Essen holen.
Komm her.
Kopf raus.
Ich hole schnell was zu essen.
So.
Oh, ich habe Hunger.
Ich werde mich jetzt mal ein bisschen
ein bisschen muten.
Oder wollt ihr die volle Social Eating
Experience? Ne, ich mute
mich jetzt. Futter mal schnell mal ein paar Nudeln.
So nebenbei.
Ein bisschen Käse drüber schmeißen.
Das ist doch was.
Samstagmittag.
Welfield 3 und Spaghetti Bolognese
fressen. So muss das sein.
Debated, outdated, overrated.
Den Destiny-Hype
verstehe ich auch nicht.
Der erste hat mich auch kalt gelassen.
Das wirkt wie so ein
MMO-Light.
Sehr light halt.
Äh.
Da ist was vor uns.
Was dickes. Und ich bin es nicht.
Null.
Wenn die rausspringen, werden sie bashed.
Ja, nehm den anderen Panzer.
Vielleicht einen Tank klauen oder so.
Au.
Hinter uns. Hinter uns.
Aber,
das ist echte Männersterben im Panzer.
MMO-RPG-Light.
Ja.
Ja, das stimmt. Also was ich an Destiny
wirklich, was mir gefallen hat, auch in der
Beta, die wir gespielt haben,
ist eindeutig das
Waffenhandling.
Das war wirklich gut.
Jetzt ein Bulan.
Das Waffenhandling
macht wirklich Spaß bei Destiny.
Der Rest
weiß ich nicht so richtig.
Was gibt denn das hier,
wenn es fertig ist?
Fahr doch einfach hier hoch.
Da lang. Da.
Hallo, Kollege.
Fahr da hoch.
Okay, ich esse mal ein paar Nudeln dabei,
bis wir das hier geschafft haben.
Hahaha.
Ich darf fahren.
Ich hoffe mal, das geht überhaupt,
dass man hier hochfahren kann.
Auf M-Track, gib Gas.
Kann man hier überhaupt hochfahren?
Ja, ne? Geht doch.
Wo war jetzt
das Problem?
Bäm.
Hallo.
Was? Moment.
Was zum Teufel? Warum kann man
da nicht drüber fahren?
Ich dachte, ich kann jetzt den Typ
überfahren.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass man den Kram nicht
überfahren kann. Stimmt, das ging eigentlich
noch nie.
Hey, sag mal.
Was ist denn hier los?
Panzer. Panz-Man.
Ich kann gerade den Chat kurz nicht verfolgen.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal hier ran.
Perfekt.
Was ist da links?
Sehen wir mal.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal gereppt werden.
Disabled?
Bäm.
Kann uns einer rappen, Peace?
Rappen, Blitz.
Nein, nicht.
Dann rappt uns keiner.
Ja.
Typischer Battlefield-Kill.
Das stimmt. Man schreibt
Lull, schreibt man
nicht mehr groß. Man schreibt nur das Buch klein.
Weil Lull größer Lull.
Ich hoffe, da sind wir uns alle einig.
Oh.
Dass Lull größer Null ist.
Äh, Lull größer Lull.
Können wir die jetzt mal aauen?
Nee, kann man nicht.
Doch, doch, doch.
Oh Mann, ey.
Mit schlägt mal Lull nach.
Come on, Prü.
Ich geh da jetzt ran.
Tja, zu spät. Zu spät.
Wo sind denn die Leute?
Kommt halt mal ran.
Der entschärft schon wieder.
Alter.
Fahr mich vor.
Was machen wir denn hier gerade?
Hier geht ja nix.
Und ich hab immer noch übelst Hunger.
Social Eating Experience.
Das ist Multi-Health.
Bombe legen, schießen und essen.
Das gibt's nur hier.
Spaghetti Bolognese gibt's.
Ich hab irgendwas gebraucht,
was einfach nur warm...
was einfach nur aufgewärmt wird.
Ich weiß das gar nicht.
Trollen wir die Gegner? Trollen uns die Gegner?
Es sieht eigentlich so aus, als könnten wir
die easy überrennen. Aber irgendwie doch nicht.
Oh oh.
Weg. Weg hier.
Uhhh.
Hey, wie geht's hier denn vorwärts?
Auf Leute.
Was?
Ja, spiel mit.
Also ich bin wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen on.
Ein paar Runden gehen noch.
Ich muss mich jetzt erstmal wieder akklimatisieren.
Nach der Call of Duty Karte.
Nach der Call of Duty Karte, ja.
Auch hier haben wir ne gute Position.
Gut Position.
Der kommt jetzt hier lang.
Wusste ich doch.
Ich bäsche alles, was hier rüber geht.
Oh, wir haben's.
Was ne schwere Geburt.
Immens schwere Geburt.
Ich hol euch.
Weiter geht's.
Oh, fuck.
Dass der hier hinten noch rumgammelt, der Hans, ne?
Klassentreff.
Viel Spaß.
Da spawn ich nicht rein.
Die sind mir viel zu frech, die Panzerfahrer hier.
Viel zu frech.
Hinter uns, hinter uns, hinter uns.
Wo kommen die denn her?
Kannst mich retzen.
Jetzt Blitz.
Das war knapp, ja.
Die Rakete war nicht.
Das war wirklich knapp.
Ja, beste Pose, beste Pose hier dahinter.
Da sieht man nämlich, ob von hier was kommt, von da was kommt.
Und dann stirbt er nicht.
Weil, auch immer, warum auch immer.
Ob von hinten was kommt.
Easy Cap.
Ihr habt bei der Twitch-TV immer ausrüstende Anzeigen.
Vor allem animiert ihr immer aus.
Geh weg, Panzer.
Kriegen wir den Panzer noch tot?
Panzer, Panzer.
Na, nein, nein, nein, lass mich in Ruhe.
Gut.
Next.
Next, please.
Ich hab deine Waffe durchguckt.
Oh, fuck.
Wo ist der Typ?
Irgendwo war doch ein Typ hinter uns gerade, oder?
Da ist er doch noch.
Da war er.
Moin, Active.
Zzt, zzt, zzt.
Da kommt ein Panzer.
Die haben wir nicht getroffen.
Oh, Mann.
Der trifft sofort, ne?
Schnub.
Uh, und wo kam das denn?
Fahren wir mal rein.
Alter, ich krieg mir so auf die Fresse.
Disabled, disabled.
Komm her.
Hunger.
Hinter uns.
Die kommen jetzt vor.
Kam's mit Defenden vorne.
Bald hier was kommt, kriegen sie aufs Maul.
Juhu, juhu, juhu, juhu.
Woll.
Wenn wir da jetzt rausgehen kriegen, wir krieg'n's nicht auf'm Sack.
Ich hoffe mal rechts ist nix.
Ah, ich hab Schiss.
Ich hab Schiss.
Huh, huh, ha, ha.
Bis dahin.
Ja, hier ist dein Schatz, Kind.
Nincon kommen.
Aber lang genug abgelenkt, dass wir legen konnten.
Lege, Henne.
Wo ist der denn hin?
Ich glaube, das war es hier, ne?
Der gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Was, der ist immer noch da.
Zu viel, zu viel, zu viel.
Hier ist ganz schlecht.
Hier kann man normalerweise nicht richtig lang pushen.
Das ist viel zu offen.
Aber jetzt fightet unser Panzer mit dem Panzer.
Da können wir vielleicht doch lang.
Lang gepusht.
Aufs Dach.
Moment, ging es dir nicht irgendwo aufs Dach?
Lege, Henne.
Defense, lege, Henne.
Sobald ihr aussteigt
und einen schaffen wollt, seid ihr
down.
Jetzt läuft es.
So, ich mute mich mal kurz
und haue mal ein bisschen Nudel rein.
Wieso fuckt die Cod-Beta ab?
Weil sie abstürzt.
Hast du das Lied von Kollegen und Fahrrad gehört?
Ne, habe ich auch kein so großes Interesse
daran, es mit uns anzuhören.
Haftbefehl, Beste.
Ne, wer mich kennt, der weiß,
Deutschrap ist eigentlich nicht so wirklich meins.
Auch wenn ich mir ab und an mal irgendwie so was
Haftbefehl oder so gebe, aber
normalerweise ist es nicht so meins.
So.
Weiter geht's.
Middest Game? Ruckels, seit ich Cod gespielt habe.
Kann doch nicht sein.
Sabotieren die anderen Games.
Lol.
Ich habe echt das Gefühl.
Ich mache Steam mal aus.
Weil Steam ist aus.
Lass ich hier durch.
Alter.
Neues Meta.
Und tschüss.
Neues Tank-Meta.
Nein, der Typ ist an B.
Entschuldige, entschuldige.
Boah, ist schon tot.
Rechts geht was?
Oh, das war knapp.
Den holen wir.
Was?
Oh, fuck, der ist hinten rumgelaufen.
Der konnte damit rechnen.
Wie lange das heutzutage dauert,
in Battlefield 3, sag ich mal.
Ne, ich habe den nicht gesehen.
Moment.
Ich dachte, der kommt links durch die Tür.
Panzer, Panzer, Panzer.
Bevor den einer klaut.
Hahaha.
Das hast du dir so vorgestellt, ne?
Origen sagt, du musst den Key einladen.
Ja.
Geben.
Hä?
Bist du vielleicht mit dem falschen Account drin?
Dann kann das sein.
Disabled.
Rekt.
Der will unseren Panzer klauen.
Was für eine Panzerschlacht hier.
Fuck, der hat unseren Panzer geklaut.
Einen Schuss kriege ich noch.
Jetzt muss ich raus.
Immerhin noch.
Einmal drauf.
Der Account ist schon der Richtige.
Ja, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Komisch.
Das hatte ich schon nie.
Okay, Battlefield repariert.
Ja, es ist halt Origen 0, ne?
Also, Origen ist halt...
Sackt per Definition.
Schnappt ihr den Panzer da an?
Fuck.
Oh, ich dachte, ich kann es jetzt wegsprayen noch.
Spiel mit Controller.
Kannst du.
Wenn du Fahrzeuge fährst, kann man das auch ganz gut mit dem Controller machen.
Wobei es halt aiming-technisch immer noch schwierig ist.
Vor allem mit den Maschinengewehren von den Fahrzeugen.
Ist mit dem Controller verdammt schwer, was zu treffen.
Ja.
Da kommt was.
Was Dickes.
Moment.
Was kommt denn da noch alles runter?
Das ist mir ein bisschen viel.
Fuck.
Wie viel kommt denn da?
Ich versuche mal, die Typen lieber abzufangen hier.
Ah, ich wusste, dass die herkommen.
Ja, Elmo, in Battlefield 3 kommt es viel drauf an, dass man weiß, wo man hin muss.
Also, ne, wo man steht, wo Zeug ist und so.
Ähm, ähm, da kommt was.
Da kommt was.
Ich steig mal aus.
Ne, ich hab nix zum rappen dabei.
Der kommt gleich von oben, der Typ.
Jebaited.
Da haben wir ihn, richtig jebaited.
Was ist denn das?
Hey.
Das war ein gestuckter ARV, oder?
Losch hat hier die M500-Tickets.
Muss ich kotzen bei sowas.
Ich war nie in großer Fähigkeit.
Ich war nie ein Fan von Noshra TDM.
Mir ist es bis heute unverständlich, warum das so viele Anhänger hatte.
Ich hab, na, ich hab Xbox gespielt, weil der Friseur eine Xbox hatte.
Weil der Friseur eine Xbox hatte und wir sau viele Games hatten einfach auf der Xbox und voll die Xbox-Fanboys gewesen sind.
Deswegen hab ich auf der Xbox gespielt, weil es einfach, wir waren die übelsten Xbox-Fanboys.
Und das war auch gerechtfertigt, finde ich, für die Planung.
weil die 360
einfach geil war
fuck
360 war die beste Konsole
au
und es gab Leute, die waren total gegen Xbox
weil PS3 for life und beste
so
das waren wenigstens noch Zeiten, so Konsolenkriege
heutzutage ist es ja so
dass man sich fast
einig schon ist, dass sowohl Xbox One als auch
PS4 sackt und von beiden
sackt eindeutig die Xbox One mehr
also PS4 ist noch die bessere Plattform
alles in allem
Games, Hardware
die haben es mit der letzten Konsolengeneration
richtig verschissen
komm, komm, komm
ja, PS4 ganz klar, diese Generation ist es nicht
mal, not even close
PS4, Xbox One
na PCs, ich weiß nicht ob
ob PCs
sagen wir mal so, PCs haben sich jetzt nicht so
fuck
Leute, geht doch mal in B ran
oh
ähm
es ist halt mittlerweile nicht mehr so
dass ich CPUs und sowas
alle paar Jahre
ver was weiß ich wie viel fachen
ich hab gestern mal geguckt
meine CPU
also mein Xeon
1230 V3
das ist eine CPU, die ist ungefähr
4 Jahre, 4,5 Jahre alt
und wenn ich mir jetzt
einen aktuellen kaufen würde
also sagen wir einen AMD Ryzen
oder wie ich das bevorzuge auszuschauen
sprich einen Ryzen
wenn ich mir jetzt einen aktuellen Ryzen 1080X kaufen würde
dann hätte das Single Core Performance
ähm 7% mehr Leistung
als meine 4,5 Jahre alte CPU
klar, insgesamt, das Ding hat doppelt so viel Kerne und sowas
hast du trotzdem 130% mehr
so, wenn du jetzt irgendwas nimmst
was dich super parallelisieren lässt
zu irgendwie Zippen oder irgendwie CPU Benchmarks
dann, klar
aber Single Core hat sich einfach wenig getan
dazu kam, dass beim Release der 360 und der PS3
die PS3 eh ein ziemlich
nennen wir es mal innovatives
Konzept hatte
und auch verdammt viel Rechenleistung
allerdings ziemlich schwierig war dafür was zu entwickeln
und auch für ihren
auch für den Zeitpunkt damals die 360
hatte auch
sehr gute Hardware
ich mein das war eine Zeit
die Xbox 360 kam raus mit 3 CPUs
zu einer Zeit wo Desktop PCs oftmals nur eine hatten
na, ich red jetzt ab
sagen wir mal Kerne
und
sie waren einfach viel leistungsfähiger für die damalige Zeit
und dazu kommt, dass sich halt auch allgemein nicht mehr so viel tut
plus die neue Generation jetzt so schwach gewesen ist
also so schwachbürstig
was Leistung anbelangt
also kein Wunder
dann, dann kommen natürlich Games wie LOL, Dota
ähm CS
und jetzt PUBG und sowas dabei
die sich halt auf dem PC einfach besser spielen
ja, und da muss man nicht lange
überlegen
warum PC wieder Master Race ist mittlerweile
warte, hier willst du klug scheißen oder was?
äh, weil die AMD CPUs keine echten Abkerne hatten
ich push da jetzt raus
easy, easy win
ich sag's noch, easy win
so, das waren jetzt meine 3 Cent zu Konsolen
aktueller Konsolengeneration
warum campen die Gegner eigentlich im eigenen Spawn?
muss man das jetzt in irgendeiner Form verstehen?
fuck
ich dachte, ich kann jetzt unten am Berg warten, bis die runtergesprungen kommen
ich hab keine Ahnung, wie die AMD FX Architektur im Kern gewesen ist
Livy, keine Ahnung
zumindest waren das Fake-Kerne
da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern
Debated-Kerne
wow
der hat auf den Sack gekriegt
aber richtig!
die rennen bestimmt voll in die Granate rein jetzt
warte jetzt mal ab
dum dum dum
wahnsinnig
ok
was macht der Amtrak da hinten?
der will gereckt werden von mir jetzt
ich hab aber leider nichts dabei
um sie zu recken
guck mal, wie hübsch die Map ist nachts, oder?
und ich hab schon nur mittlere Grafik oder so, dass ich halt 144 FPS hab
guck mal, wie hübsch die Map nachts ist
aber ich glaub auch, das sind halt so Fake-Lichter, sind ja keine echten, oder?
ähm
das sieht doch echt gut aus für ein Game von 2011
also da hat sich wenig getan, cpu-technisch, die letzten Jahre
also Single core fast, Single Threads
meine CDU
Klar Multi-Threading
und mehrere Kerne und
und so Sachen wird immer wichtiger
klar
aber es gibt einfach Aufgaben, die sich halt
nicht unendlich parallelisierten lassen
Und es wird immer wichtig bleiben, dass eine CPU halt auch einzelne Sachen schnell ausführen
kann.
Weil was hast du davon, wenn du eine CPU hast mit 16 Kernen und du aber eine Aufgabe hast,
die sich nicht gescheit auf 16 Kerne verteilen lässt?
Na, hast du gelitten.
Dann ist besser, dann rechne nur mit 1, 2 und dafür ordentlich mit Bums.
Warte, ich dachte der ist down.
Da habe ich das überlebt gerade.
Demnächst kommt auch eine neue Intel-Generation, hab ich gelesen, irgendwie 5.
Oktober.
Wow.
Und ich hoffe, dass dann endlich auch mal ein bisschen mehr als 4, 4 Kerne Standard
werden, werden, werden, Scheißsatz, dass es dann auch mal standardmäßig mehr als
4 Kerne gibt, ohne dass man zu tiefe liegt.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das in die Tasche greifen muss.
Weil ich war schon kurz davor, mir einen Ryzen zu bestellen jetzt.
Ich brauche ja, im Prinzip, ich brauche ein Mainboard, eine CPU, RAM und das war's.
Netzteil habe ich, Gehäuse habe ich, Grafikkarte habe ich, SSD habe ich.
Fuck.
Ich bleibe jetzt mal hinten.
Ich habe keinen Bock, dass wir jetzt so ab...
Oh, ne.
Echt.
So.
Ähm.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ja, ich war kurz davor, mir einen Ryzen zu bestellen.
Oh, ne.
Ich war kurz davor, mir einen Ryzen zu kaufen.
Mit 8 Kernen.
Aber da habe ich gesehen, nächste Woche oder übernächste Woche stellt Intel ihr neues
Zeug vor.
Ich muss mal abwarten.
Mal gucken.
Aber ich habe halt kaum Gewinn dadurch, was jetzt, was jetzt halt Single Threat Performance
anbelangt.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, in Games ist auch ein aktueller Ryzen nicht so viel
schneller als mein 4 Jahre alter...
Äh.
Xeon CPU.
Schon schneller.
Ja.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise hier in...
In, ähm.
In der Core Beta, sagen wir mal, wenn ich da 60 FPS hatte und meine Grafikkarte, an
der liegt es ja nur beim besten Willen nicht, dann glaube ich nicht, dass ich auf einmal
140 habe.
Ne?
Nur wegen der neuen CPU.
Da habe ich vielleicht statt 60 habe ich dann, keine Ahnung, 68 oder so.
So.
Ich mute mich nochmal kurz und futter den Rest.
Oh, ne.
Fuck me.
Nach der Runde muss ich mir noch was zu essen holen.
Reicht nicht.
Nicht genug.
Pass auf.
Der wird jetzt geowned.
Ich own jetzt den Chat.
Easy.
Easy Mode.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Guckt euch das an.
Skiller Nummer 1.
Ja, ja.
Fahr ruhig.
Da ist ein Panzer.
Ich verstecke mich.
Siehst mich nicht.
Lol.
Hehehe.
Oh, ne.
Fuck.
Ah.
Alter.
Zwei.
Braucht ihr jetzt zwei Panzer um mich zu ownen oder was?
Alter.
Die haben zwei Panzer und die brauchen sie für mich vorne am Arsch der Welt hinter dem
Stein.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen oder was?
Wollt ihr mich rollen?
Jawoll.
Rekt.
Tyrannosaurus rekt.
So.
Ich bleib jetzt einfach hier stehen.
Was?
Gibt's nicht.
Umgerotzt.
Test dich, Alter.
Hm.
Waa.
Schreck mich nicht so.
Gehrtiger.
Ja.
Ja, das eine Problem, was ich aktuell noch hab, ist, seitdem ich hier beim, beim HNO-Arzt
gewesen bin und der hier die Ohre, die Ohren gesaugt, spült, sonst was hat, seitdem piepst
mein rechtes Ohr nachts.
Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist.
Das ist so leise, das hör ich tagsüber nicht.
Aber nachts nervt's manchmal.
Ich guck jetzt mal, dass es wieder weg geht.
Wenn es nicht wieder weg geht, muss ich dann auch mal hin.
Ich hab überhaupt keinen Bock.
Ich geh ja nicht gern zu irgendwelchen Ärzten.
Oh, ne Entzündung.
Nee, es tut nichts weh.
Ja, glaub ich nicht, dass die entzündet ist.
Wobei, man weiß ja nicht, ne.
Es muss ja nicht alles wehtun, was schlecht ist.
Also, wenn es jetzt noch bis, bis nächste Woche nicht besser ist, nächste Woche ist
dann, dann muss ich da noch mal hin.
Leute, genau, eventuelle Depression.
Das checkt jetzt wahrscheinlich keiner, der das Video nicht gesehen hat.
Damit, da waren die Homie-Psychologen damals am Start auf YouTube, ja.
Was?
Warum, warum weißt du, dass ich da bin?
Cheat!
Bann!
Instant Bann!
Gut, wahrscheinlich hat mich einfach einer gespottet.
Ja, wo ist der Magic Train?
Das frag ich mich auch.
Wo ist der Magic Train?
Okay, ja, mach mal da eine extra Runde hier.
Kann ich noch den Rest futtern.
Dann muss ich mir noch was holen.
Warum geht der verquickte Baum nicht kaputt?
Ich seh nichts.
Ich guck mal, ob ich hinten noch was erwische.
Ja, direkt.
Auch vor dem, vor dem, vor dem Flugzeug hab ich Schiss.
Ich hab schon mal gesaved das Ganze.
Ich hab schon mal gesaved.
Ich, ich rapp dich.
Ich rapp dich.
Wo ist der Typ hin?
Vorne ist noch ein Panzer.
Sobald die aussteigen, werden sie geoutet.
Was?
Wie ist das Ding denn geflogen jetzt?
Na, tauscht ihr im Chat gerade eure Vorlieben aus.
Ich mein, jedem, was ihm gefällt.
Ich hab dazu meins fallen fest.
Nicht unbedingt.
Aber jedem, wem das gefällt.
Ist ja heutzutage kein Problem.
Kanickel.
Ja, Kanickel.
Ist ja kein Problem, wenn einem das gefällt.
Ich hab dazu meins fallen fest.
Nicht unbedingt.
Aber jedem, wem das gefällt.
Ist ja heutzutage kein Problem.
Kanickel.
Ja, Kanickel.
Ist ja kein Problem, wenn einem das gefällt.
Wie du willst.
Lull.
Boah, treff ich nicht.
Ich geh da jetzt rein.
Jetzt wird's...
Lege, Henne.
Ich hab mich übrigens vertan im Haus.
Pff.
Ich dachte, das...
Oh, fuck.
Der lebt noch, ne?
Der Sniper!
Sag mal, kriegst du gar nichts mit, Alter?
Boah.
Ich hasse diese Ziele.
Oh, fuck.
Der lebt noch, ne?
Der Sniper!
Sag mal, kriegst du gar nichts mit, Alter?
Boah.
Ich hasse diese Ziele.
Der Sniper!
Sag mal, mit an.
Geht doch.
Der Sniper!
Oh, geil, Alter.
Boah.
Der Sniper!
Oh, boah.
Ich hab eine Dose Spitzpapier.
Scheiße.
C4 am M-Koms.
So ne Kacke.
Richtig ehrenloser Kram.
Richtig ehrenlos.
Ich leg jetzt.
Lege, Henne.
Pass auf, der C4t mich jetzt gleich wieder.
Muss ich mitfahren.
Gleich bin ich wieder da.
So, wir haben Start.
Ups.
Oh man.
Ich habe meinen ersten Halb auf dem Mausplatt stehen.
Ich kann kaum den Maus bewegen.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Oh.
Moment, warum habe ich den nicht getroffen?
Warum trifft der mich?
Der ist drei Kilometer oben drüber.
So, jetzt haben wir...
Super.
Jetzt haben wir uns gegenseitig gekillt.
Perfekt.
Gestern hatte Cotton noch 40.000 Zuschauer.
Heute sind es 1.000.
Ja, das Spiel kackt die ganze Zeit ab.
Es hat wortwörtlich verkackt.
Oh, mir geht es ja gar nicht lang.
Oh.
Was war denn das?
Hat wortwörtlich verkackt.
Gut, schon wiederbelebt.
Nice.
Tix.
Achtung, Skillshot-Panzer.
Panzerbech.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Leute, jetzt.
Boah.
Achtung, das hier.
Und, und, und, und.
Boah.
Na gut.
Jetzt machst du es mir aber einfach.
Oh, oh.
Nope, nope, nope.
Warte mal, nope.
Die haben es aber auf mich abgesehen jetzt.
Random Name.
Naja.
Es macht Spaß.
Weil es neu ist.
Aber es kackt ab.
Es ist der uninstabilste Kackport, den ich je gesehen habe.
Schon mal ein neuer Panzer.
Unser Pilot scheint da ganz schön zu ownen.
Er schnappt sich doch den anderen Panzer halt.
Moment.
Warum habe ich keinen Zoom?
Warum habe ich denn keinen Zoom?
Ich habe keinen Zoom.
Ich habe zwar Zoom ausgerüstet, aber ich habe keinen Zoom.
Auch gut.
Ich hätte gerne meinen Zoom wieder.
Gibt es aber nicht.
Achtung, jetzt.
Was zum...
Oh, ich schnuppe.
Ich habe nicht auf die Minimap geguckt.
Ah.
Wie der letzte Kack.
Jetzt machen sie auch noch Legehennen.
Eigentlich hätte man das easy runterspielen können.
Fast so OP wie die Kotschop Gun.
Ähm, ja John.
Das glaube ich auch.
Die meisten Leute wollen nicht, dass Call of Duty Coast anders ist.
Hat man ja auch gesehen die letzten Jahre.
Wobei ich fand, dass dieses Rumspringen jetzt...
Man muss unterscheiden zwischen
man macht was anders und man macht was anders.
anders aber scheiße und ich finde das rumspringen war halt meine macht es
anders aber scheiße also es heißt nicht dass das war nicht
bei call of duty auch was anders machen kann und das funktioniert aber das
rumspringen hat ein null gepasst vor allem die maps haben auch absolut nicht
dazu gepasst
ich weiß du hattest maps auf den kopf
ja du hattest maps da kannst du zwar rumspringen aber es sah so aus als
konntest du drüber und konntest du da nicht beinahe call of duty map und so
also das war halt was anders gemacht aber scheiße und das haben sie halt
einfach mal gnadenlos 3 call of duties durchgezogen
und nicht dass ich jetzt scheiße erzähle 3
advanced warfare war gespringe black ops 3 war gespringe was war das
nächste was war das nächste black ops 3 kam da
noch was
auch infinity war für das habe ich ja schon das habe ich wieder vergessen als
ich den trailer gesehen haben das war das ungedeuteste von all sogar
der trailer war fail ich würde gerne wieder blieben
gucken wir mal ob der typ hier doch wird auf auf das knapp
die frage mich wo das team ist team
Please, wo seid ihr?
Ernsthaft, wo seid ihr dann?
Dass wir das nochmal gekriegt haben, war nice.
Entschuldige.
In den Jet aufpassen.
Wo Job hat's?
Schnippt.
Schneibt er sich einen ab?
Ach, der ist jetzt voll.
Lass das Haus mal stehen, Panzer.
Das ist für uns zum Defenden gar nicht verkehrt.
Dass da noch ein Haus steht.
Ja, Infinite Warfare, Leute,
hab ich komplett vergessen, dass es das überhaupt je gegeben hat.
Habt ihr das gespielt?
Wie war das? Wie war Infinite Warfare?
Erklärt mir das mal, Blitz.
Hat alles was getaugt?
Ist ja scheiße.
War wirklich so scheiße, okay.
Vielleicht haben sie es ja in der Twents Warfare,
äh, sorry, in Infinite Warfare,
ich hab's nicht gespielt,
zum ersten Mal geschafft, gescheite Maps zu bauen
für die Jetpack-Geschichte.
Der Typ nervt mich.
Die ersten Stunden können Bock machen.
Ja, so war's ja auch hier in der, in der,
in der, Dings hier, in der Beta,
in der aktuellen.
Uh!
Hat Bock gemacht?
Hätte auch weiter Bock gemacht?
Ist gar nicht mal so sehr die Schuld von dem...
Mop, mop, mop, mop.
Kann mir das mal einer erklären,
gerade was das gewesen ist?
Kann mir das einer erklären?
Halt, Magazin auf die Gegner draufgeschossen,
nix passiert.
Und dann instant gestorben.
Steigt aus.
Ja.
Uh!
Fast mover.
Entschuldige.
Sag mal.
Ist mit dem Typ alles in Ordnung?
Der One-Shotte mir ein bisschen zu gut.
Weil das kann ja alles noch sein.
Seit wann spielst du wieder
Aktiv-Battlefield 1?
Gar nicht?
Ähm.
Die Spielerzahlen auf dem PC,
das ist auch lächerlich.
Es sind irgendwie,
ungefähr,
ich hab jetzt keine genauen Zahlen,
weil ich heute noch reingeguckt hab,
es sind aber ungefähr irgendwie
40k Battlefield 1,
20k Battlefield 4,
5k Battlefield 3.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Battlefield 3 und 4 zusammenspielen
fast so viel wie Battlefield 1.
Auf dem PC.
Und PC ist eigentlich die beste Version.
Hallo,
Cesar.
Oh, das ist...
Panzer.
Petspan.
Jetzt ist alles kaputt.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
wo ich mir hinstellen soll.
Ich kann versuchen,
den Typ, der repariert,
zu bashen.
Kommt noch was?
Ich hab's nicht.
Sag mal.
Sterben, please.
Oh.
Den holen wir uns jetzt.
Tja.
Jetzt hol ich euch, Jungs.
Piep.
Ey, mein Ratz.
Mein Ratz.
Oh.
Voll ins Rohr gerannt.
Es gab mal Hardline plus BF4
plus alle DLCs für ein paar Euro.
Okay.
Ähm.
Hardline.
Ja, Hardline hab ich auch noch.
Ich glaub, Hardline...
Letztens war da was dazu.
Ich glaub, Hardline spielen noch 300 Leute.
300.
Es gibt noch einen Server, der voll ist.
Oder halb voll.
War halb voll.
Wir haben das letzte Mal geguckt.
Wir können gleich nochmal gucken.
Wir können gleich nochmal Hardline-Stats gucken.
Es war so der Rohrgrip hier,
war schlechthin Hardline.
Battlefield 4 kam einfach zu schnell.
Und hat es zu scheiße...
Der Start war zu scheiße.
Mittlerweile ist Battlefield 4 ganz okay.
Aber ich find immer noch quasi 3,5
plus jetzt spielbar.
Es kam einfach zu früh Battlefield 4.
Die hätten lieber ein neues Bad Company machen sollen.
In der Zwischenzeit.
Oder in der, keine Ahnung, in der Vietnam 2 oder was weiß ich.
Das an Battlefield 4...
In Battlefield 4 hätte ja keiner was gesagt.
So, jetzt könnte beispielsweise Battlefield 4 kommen.
So 2017, das wär okay gewesen.
Oder 16 oder so, ne?
So 5 Jahre dazwischen ist okay.
N.A.A.M.
Oh, ich hab mich fast selbst geouten mit der Granate.
Oh, wie dumm.
Alter, wie dumm.
Ach, der Chat war das.
War nicht der Chat, das war Teamkill,
weil ich ins Haus gerannt bin.
Teamkill.
Ja, viel konnte man jetzt nicht machen in der Runde.
Ich mag die Map auch nicht.
Lull, größer Lull.
Also quasi
Juhl, größer Lull.
Irgendwo ist hier was.
Versuchen wir nochmal einen Kill zu machen.
Irgendwo müsste hier noch was sein.
Ist eh aber nix.
Wie lange bin ich denn heute eigentlich schon am streamen?
Ab 10, ne?
Jetzt 4 1⁄2 Stunden.
Ich gucke jetzt mal in die Follows.
Oh, danke für die ganzen Follows.
40 Follows, nice.
Ne, Statistik, das war vorgestern.
Vorgestern waren es auch 53.
Leider habe ich keine gescheite History dafür.
Hehehe.
So, das war's.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Entschuldige.
Verpackt, verpackt, die sind hinten.
Ja, da konnte ich jetzt nichts machen.
Wo war denn unser Team?
Die hätten sich alle mal hier reinstellen sollen.
Spielst du noch Overwatch?
Ab und zu mal.
Aber nachdem ich das Rank-System in Overwatch so fertig gemacht jedes Mal,
hab ich eigentlich keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Das Spiel ist so gut, Overwatch.
So ein geiles Game.
Und so ein verkacktes Rank-System.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, warum ich da so dumm
auch an der Laterne hängen geblieben bin.
Also Quickplay ist scheiße, genau.
So sieht's aus.
Das ist das Problem von Overwatch.
Quickplay kannst du komplett vergessen.
Und Ranked, der Modus, der eigentlich
ordentlich sein sollte, ist verkackt.
Das ist ziemlich doof für das Spiel.
Weil wie gesagt, Overwatch ist
ein so geiles Game.
Gibt's doch nicht, dass wir jetzt hier so gerackt werden.
Mit dem Typ stimmt was nicht.
Okay.
Das geht alles.
So schnell tot.
Mit der PP aus der Range.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie.
Aber geht schon.
Du hast nur Quickplay gespielt.
Ich find, das Problem bei Quickplay ist,
also in Ranked versuchen die Leute ja teilweise noch zusammen zu spielen.
In Quickplay kannst du's voll vergessen.
In Quickplay hast du nicht mal mehr gescheite Team-Compositions.
In Quickplay hast du dann
Torb Symmetra.
Als DPS und sowas.
Torb Symmetra DPS.
Das ist dann halt nicht so geil, ne?
Typischer Battlefield-Kill.
Warum ist das Ranked-System dann scheiße?
Das Overwatch-Ranked-System ist scheiße.
Erstens, weil's One-Trick-Leute bevorzugt.
Also sprich, weil's versucht irgendwie rauszufinden, wie gut die Leute, wie gut oder schlecht die Leute in der Klasse spielen.
Was du halt einfach nicht anhand von Stats...
Du kannst Teamplay nicht anhand von Stats festmachen.
Z.B.
Ähm, gehen wir mal vor einem einfachen Held auf, sowas wie Mercy.
So.
Ist das Team schlecht und du kriegst die ganze Zeit auf den Sack.
Ähm, sagt das nicht drüber aus, wie gut oder schlecht du Mercy spielst.
Von den Heal-Stats her.
Ist das Team gut und reckt die Gegner, hast du kaum Heal.
Das heißt, das Game denkt, du spielst schlecht Mercy.
Obwohl du vielleicht gar nicht zum Zuge gekommen bist, weil du die Gegner total zerbersten hast.
Obwohl.
Oh fuck.
Oh fuck, was ist hier los?
Äh, es ist nicht mit Loss passiert.
Und das in Kombination mit der ganzen One-Trick-Scheiße.
Es matcht Leute miteinander, die normalerweise gar nicht miteinander spielen könnten.
Also du bist Top 500 und wirst mit Diamond gematcht.
Es ist überhaupt nicht aussagekräftig.
Hallo?
Was geht denn hier gerade?
Was, was war denn das jetzt?
Hä?
Du bist ja nicht gestorben.
So, und irgendwas habe ich noch vergessen.
Irgendeinen wichtigen Punkt am Rank-System habe ich noch vergessen, der mich so richtig
abfällt.
Wichtiger Punkt.
Aber fällt mir gerade nicht ein.
Es gibt, es gibt so drei, vier Punkte, die das Rank-System einfach kacke machen.
Was ist hier los in dem Haus gerade?
Kriege ich ein Red?
Danke.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir wirklich zurück.
Komm her.
NA-Aim.
Hardcore NA-Aim.
Was war, was, was liegt der Typ da eigentlich?
Nee, er konnte es nicht machen.
Was hältst du von Pupke?
Also ihr wisst ja, es heißt Pupke.
Alle, die das PUBG aussprechen, das ist falsch.
Pupke ist richtig.
Ähm.
Ja, es ist spannend.
Es ist spannend.
Es kann jeder spielen und ein paar coole Aktionen haben.
Man profitiert aber schon davon, wenn man es gut kann.
Auch wenn es halt einfach random ist, so mit dem Spawn und sowas.
Also sprich, wo Items spawnen.
Ähm.
Ansonsten checke ich diesen ganzen Battle-Royale-Hype nicht so ganz, ehrlich gesagt.
Also diesen Battle-Royale-Hype checke ich nicht.
Was ich für einen Drehstuhl habe.
Ich habe ein, ähm.
Senus Mr.24 Leitwartenstuhl.
Das Ding heißt wirklich so.
Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Senus Mr.24 Leitwartenstuhl.
Ja, aber fragt mich ruhig noch Zeug.
Ich bin gerade so im Redefluss irgendwie.
Und außerdem bin ich komplett im Arsch schon, weil ich jetzt schon 5 Stunden spiele.
Und mich eh kaum noch konzentriert kann auf das Game.
Ja.
Actives.
Ist gut, ich meine, ist ja auch klar.
Man muss überlegen, wo das Ganze herkommt.
Kein Wunder, dass es einen Hauch von AMA und DLC hat.
Kein DX Racer.
Nee, kein DX Racer.
Ich hatte mal einen DX Racer.
Und da ist dann die Lehne abgebrochen.
Roblox habe ich keine Meinung zu.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Ich weiß jetzt gerade mal mit Ach und Krach, was es ist.
Oder ich glaube, ich weiß, was es ist.
Ist das dieses Minecraft, dieser Minecraft-Shooter, den irgendein 15-Jähriger alleine programmiert hat?
Hallo, L.A.V.
Move dich.
Ich warte eigentlich, dass jemand bei A legt jetzt, aber...
War ich von der Switch halt, oder?
Da sage ich gleich was zu.
Erinnert mich dran, dass ich was dazu sage, sobald ich hier raus bin.
Sobald ich Zeit habe, sage ich was zur Switch.
Äh.
Oh Mann!
Jetzt sind wir so gut durchgekommen.
Aber ich bin halt verreckt, weil ich nicht moven konnte, während man legt.
Was denn?
Was denn für ein Scherzsack ist?
Wenn wir jetzt schnell pushen, kommen wir da durch.
Wir dürfen jetzt nicht so lange.
Wir müssen jetzt mit allen Mannen drauf.
Ratsblitz.
Sag mal, Leute, pusht halt mit!
Kann das so schwer sein, ja?
Rein, Leute, rein!
Wollt ihr die diffusen lassen, oder was?
Rein!
Okay.
NA Suppression.
Jetzt...
Yeah, yeah.
Huge place!
Massive!
Jetzt habe ich sie gereckt, hä?
Ähm, ja.
Zur Switch.
Ähm.
Switch, finde ich, ist eine super Konsole.
Also von der Plattform her.
Das einzige, was mir halt fehlt, sind Games.
So blöd es klingt.
Sagen wir mal so.
Es ist halt einfach so.
Jetzt fehlen mir Games.
Lohnt es sich noch, auf den Server zu kommen?
Klar.
Ist doch Platz.
Go, go.
Jetzt fehlen Games.
Nintendo hat wie immer keine Ahnung, wie man einen gescheiten Online-Modus macht.
Weil es halt Nintendo ist.
Die können das...
Die kriegen das einfach nicht hin.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man sich mittlerweile die letzten 12 Jahre Entwicklung angucken könnte
und sich dann abschauen, wie man es halbwegs richtig macht, ja?
Und, weil...
Es kann ja nicht sein...
Fuck.
Es kann ja nicht sein, dass eine Plattform von 2005...
Mit besserem Online...
Was ist hier drinnen los, ey?
Besseren Online-Modus hat, wie eine Plattform von 2014...
Äh, wie von 2017.
Das geht nicht.
Das kriegt nur Nintendo hin.
Also ich verstehe das nicht.
Und dann auch diese Platoon App und so, eine Kacke.
Was macht Nintendo denn da?
Und dann soll man auch noch was dafür bezahlen.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist das denn? Nintendo kriegt... Warum kriegt ihr die Scheiße nicht hin?
Ich meine, mehr Leute killen kann ich gerade nicht.
Ich sag...
Ich sag gleich noch was zur Switch.
Es kommen ein paar gute Games, ja.
Es sind ja mittlerweile auch schon ein paar gute Games da und es kommen noch ein paar gute Games.
Aber es reicht jetzt halt nicht, um es als alleinige Plattform so zu tragen irgendwie, ne?
Wenn man nur das hätte und sonst nix.
Aber was mich am meisten nervt, ist, dass Nintendo den Online-Modus nicht geschissen bekommt.
Ihr könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen, wie man das auf den Sack geht.
Warum, Nintendo? Warum?
Und dann, wie gesagt, dann lief's Platoon-App und so ne Kacke.
Und am schlimmsten...
...sind dann die Nintendo-Fanboys.
Die einem erzählen wollen, ja, Nintendo will das gar nicht.
Wie bescheuert kann man eigentlich sein?
Warum sollte das Nintendo nicht wollen?
Will Nintendo kein Geld verdienen?
Oder was?
Nintendo hätt's nötig, Kohle zu verdienen.
Warum soll das Nintendo nicht wollen?
Man muss der Realität mal ins Auge sehen.
Nintendo kann es nicht.
Die kriegen es nicht gebacken.
Was anderes anders, da kann ich mir sowas wie die Splatoon-App zum Beispiel am besten nicht erklären.
Können ist einfach nicht.
So als hätten sie, als würden sie quasi Bewerber ganz streng, ähm, einteilen.
So nach dem Motto, jeder, der halbwegs was kann...
...wird für Spieleentwicklung und drumherum eingeplant und verwendet.
Und jeder, der suckt, der wird für alles andere verwendet.
Anders, da kann ich mir's wirklich nicht erklären, dass Nintendo quasi jahrzehntelang richtig geile Games macht, aber alles drumherum verscheißt.
Sag mal, wie viele Leute soll ich eigentlich noch killen gerade?
Ey, was die Splatoon-App macht, die Splatoon ist quasi ne, ne, ne Freundesliste...
...also ich hab's nicht ausprobiert, ich hab das Game nicht.
Ähm, ist quasi so ne, so ne Voice-Chat-Freundesliste.
Ähm...
...Funktion in einem.
Problem ist nur, dass man dafür halt nen Smartphone braucht.
Also zusätzlich, als zusätzlicher Service, wäre das ja gar kein Problem.
Dass sich Nintendo irgendwie nicht überlegt hat, dass man vielleicht mal nen Headset anschließen will zum Kommunizieren an die, an die...
...Switch.
Ähm, und jetzt halt so ne komische App am Start hat.
Die man quasi braucht.
Und die dazu noch nicht mal die, die Grundlagen dessen, was jede Voice-Chat und, und, ähm...
...Messenger-App auf nem Smartphone...
hat eben beachtet ja du kannst nicht raus tappen wo ist denn da der sinn
davon ja du musst deine switch anhaben wer hat sich denn so was nintendo war
was war warum auf dem smartphone app die man immer offen haben muss also immer
der sinn wäre ja noch weißt du wenn man unterwegs wenn man unterwegs keine ahnung
ich fahre von der arbeit ich werde jetzt mal angenommen ich werde über krasses
platoon owner und wird tag ein tag ausspielen und ich würde dann heim
fahren und dann kann ich quasi während ich im zug sitze schon meine krassen mit
platoon owner anschreiben und sagen hier jungs sieht aus platoon war schon mal
lobby auf und sobald ich daheim bin sage ich login meine switch geht automatisch
an erstellt die lobby startet könnte man alles so schön machen ist es halt nicht
dann das segen das unsägliche p2p gehostet bei splatoon p2p hosting
ist einfach absolut cancer es ist einfach so p2p hosting ist der größte
scheiß und irgendwie schaffen es die hersteller immer wieder leute davon zu
überzeugen dass es nicht der größte scheiß ist ich frag mich halt wie sie
das machen weil man hat zwei guckt euch an for honor war das beste beispiel
wieder voran wird angekündigt so denke fragt man soja wie sieht's aus mit server
nein wir machen p2p leute wieder übelst am heulen dann bringen sie so eine
halbherzige begründung raus soja
wegen Reaktionszeiten und sonst was,
ähm, da müssen wir jetzt
quasi P2P-Hosting machen. Und sofort
wieder die Leute, ah, Max, du hast ja
überhaupt keine Ahnung, P2P ist das
einzig wahre Info-Honor und es geht nicht
ohne und, ähm, ich sollte
nicht so viel labern, sondern einfach spielen.
Ähm, und es muss P2P sein
und sonst was, ähm,
und jetzt ist das Game raus,
gleich instant Verbindungspro...
Das Game ist ja schon eine Weile was. Verbindungsprobleme,
Cheater am Start,
Leg-Switcher am Start, der ganze
Scheiß, die ganze Palette von Bullshit,
die du immer P2P hast, aber nein!
Das ist natürlich bei For Honor bestimmt
ganz anders. Wer hätte sich das gedacht?
Äh, warum schiebst du nicht?
Ja, und das war bei For Honor auch so. Da hat's gesehen,
wie beschissen P2P ist. P2P ist die
beschissenste Sache, die so Multiplayer-Stile ever.
Man sollte die, man sollte Hersteller, die
auf einer Plattform P2P-Games veröffentlichen,
Multiplayer, sollte man einfach für immer
bannen von dieser Plattform Sachen.
Öffnen Sie die Tür. So.
Ich geb zu, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen radikal
jetzt.
Ich hab ne Switch.
Ich hab ne Switch. Ich hab seit Release
ne Switch. Wer spielt eigentlich
noch For Honor? Da sieht man's mal wieder.
Was ein gutes Game, also das Kampfsystem
war wirklich gut.
Was ein scheiß
Hosting und Verbindungsprobleme bei Release
aus dem Game machen. For Honor
ein Game mit wirklich keinem schlechten
Kampfsystem und an sich nicht
übel oder so,
total selbst geownt
wieder durch Server-Kacke
und P2P-Kacke.
Was ist hier eigentlich los in dem Haus
gerade?
Ja, ich bin auch sehr gehypt
auf das neue Mario.
Das, das versteh ich halt nicht.
Nintendo macht seit,
seit wann hab ich
Spaß bei meinen ersten Nintendo-Konsolen, der Super Nintendo?
Das war mal so irgendwie 92 oder sowas.
Wenn man sich überlegt,
92.
25 Jahre jetzt einfach mal, ne?
Warum hat das nicht wieder geblieben?
Nintendo macht jetzt, zumindest aus meiner Sicht,
weil ab da hab ich angefangen, seit 25
Jahren kontinuierlich richtig geile
Spiele.
Aber sie verkacken
ihre ganzen Plattformen einfach.
Und wir haben's ja auch dem Verkacken von
Nintendo zu verdanken, dass es überhaupt ne Playstation
gibt. Nintendo
verkackt's einfach gerne.
So, jetzt muss ich mich auch wieder ein bisschen auf das Game
konzentrieren.
N.A.A.M.
Airzone, die macht's ja auch richtig.
Die konzentrieren sich eben auf das, was
sie können.
Bei der PS4 zumindest.
Die haben jetzt ne Plattform, die ist etabliert,
die mag jetzt zwar Hardware-mäßig
nicht Bäume ausreißen oder so,
die ist etabliert,
die ist verbreitet, die sorgen jetzt einfach dafür, dass
gute Games rauskommen, dass PSN gut funktioniert,
dass die Leute sich wohlfühlen auf
der Plattform, alles das, was Nintendo nicht gebacken kriegt.
Obwohl Nintendo die besseren Explosionen,
Obwohl Nintendo die besseren Explosionen, die es gibt, hat Nintendo nicht gebacken.
Naja, ne kann man so nicht sagen.
Aber ich sag mal die einzigartigeren
exclusive Spiel, mit dem Nintendo spiel.
Moment
Was??
Ich hab extra nochmal nachgelegt
weil ich mir gedacht hab der ist
wääh
warum is der eben nich gestoormn?
Die Balance ist n bisschen Kacka.
Jaa
Ich weiß nicht was Nintendo macht
Ich verstehs einfach nich.
Ich...
Ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen.
Was zum Teufel?
Will er den Road killen oder was?
Das hast du sehr gut gemacht, Heli-Typ.
Rekt.
So geht das.
So macht man das.
Ja, kein Klinke-Ausgang.
Das ist genau sowas, Elmo.
Genau sowas.
Man versteht es nicht.
Als, als...
Wie kann man das vergessen, dass man daran ein Headset anschließen kann?
Die Balance ist aber ganz schön von Arsch, ne?
Sag mal, kann da mal was sterben jetzt?
Was?
Ja, ich verstehe es auch nicht, was die da machen.
Die Switch ans Plattformen finde ich gut.
Die Balance ist nicht so gegeben gerade.
Okay.
Hinten verboten.
Oh, mehr.
Rekt.
Ja, Zelda ist auch das einzige Spiel, was ich auf der Switch habe.
Hallo?
Treffen, please.
No, nicht treffen.
Rats, please.
Nochmal Ratsblitz.
Ratsblitz, Ratsblitz, Blitz.
Ja.
Mario Kart ist übrigens auch wieder ein schöner Beispiel für Nintendo Online-Fail, ne?
So nach dem Motto Multiplayer, ohne dass man eine Ahnung hat, wie man ordentlich Multiplayer-Spiele macht.
Und ich rede davon nicht, wie das Game gebalanced ist oder sonst was, weil da geht es bei Mario Kart nicht drum.
Ich rede von Verbindungsgeschichten, also wie die Games gehostet werden, dass das alles kleinseitig ist, kleinseitig Hint-Detection, kleinseitig Positionen der Karts.
Mach's gut, Levy.
Kleinseitige Position der Karts ist richtiger Fail.
Kann ich hier noch irgendwo rein, wo ein bisschen mehr los ist?
Die sacken alle.
Fall back, B.
Blärt.
D-Sync-Kart, genau so ist das.
D-Sync-Kart.
Also du hast Leute in ihren Karts quasi an Stellen, wo sie gar nicht sind.
Und nachdem es Kleinseitig Hint-Detection ist, beziehungsweise halt Position und alles und...
Also nicht gleich...
Ne, also sprich...
Wenn es so aussieht, als fährt der bei euch in den Abgrund, dann sieht das nur so aus, aber sicher ist er nicht in den Abgrund gefahren, so nach dem Motto, ne?
Es ist halt ein Fail.
Was Nintendo mal zur Abwechslung wieder ganz gut macht, ist, dass es jetzt auch Third-Party-Support gibt.
Auf der Switch.
Auch wenn nur ein bisschen halbherzig, wenn man sich das neue FIFA anguckt, was als einziges FIFA noch mit Alter Engine läuft.
Aber immerhin.
FIFA ist wichtig, FIFA hat viele Fanboys.
Konsole mit FIFA ist erfolgreicher als Konsole ohne FIFA.
Weil FIFA.
Weil, ich weiß nicht.
Weil Leute auf...
Fußballspiele stehen.
Verstehe nicht, verstehe nicht.
FIFA...
Verstehe das auch nicht.
Also warum man so auf FIFA steht.
Kann mir das jemand erklären, warum man so auf FIFA steht?
Mein Aim ist richtig krass gerade, ne?
Ich bin den Typ wieder bedroht, glaube ich.
Bestes Aim.
Aim des Jahrtausends.
Die flanken wir jetzt.
Sag mal, was ist das für eine Balance?
Was ist das für eine Balance?
Ja, Skyrim Neuauflage ist grenzwertig.
Wie oft wollen sie das Game noch releasen?
Die flanken wir jetzt, ja.
Hey.
Das hätte gut funktionieren können.
Hat Potential für nice Plays gehabt.
Mod-Support gibt es eh wahrscheinlich nicht für Skyrim auf der Switch, ja.
Ich verstehe, also Skyrim ist auch ein Game.
Wo ich den...
Diesen extremen Hype von mich verstanden habe.
Ein nicer Flank.
Das war ein nicer Flank.
Richtig nicer Flank war das.
Na, mehr kann ich da nur beim besten Willen nicht machen.
Skyrim fand ich ohne Mods...
Ehrlich gesagt, oder generell fand ich Skyrim...
Also mit Mods vielleicht.
Wenn das halt...
Das Ganze noch ein bisschen erweitert.
Aber ansonsten...
Was ist hier los?
Ich verstehe es halt...
Ich kann es nachvollziehen, aber nicht begreifen, warum Skyrim so beliebt ist.
Ich bin nicht gerade der einzige, der was killt, mal so gefragt.
Ja, ich dachte scheiße.
Bad Luck?
Ich dachte ich bin gestorben, weil der Panzer neben mir in die Luft geflogen ist.
Oder nicht?
Ich finds beeindruckend, dass Battlefield...
3...
Side Release noch Spaß macht.
Und es einem nicht...
so zum Hals raushängt, dass man das nicht mehr spielen will.
Ähm...
ee...kaiiitl
ee...kaiitl
Wie spricht man das aus?
Ähm...oh.
Battlefield 1 wird noch gespielt, aber nicht so viel...
wie man das sich vielleicht erhofft hat.
Also Battlefield 4...
und Battlefield 3 zusammen haben...
fast, fast...
weniger. Fast so viele Spiele auf dem PC wie Battlefield 1. Und es ist halt schon ein bisschen lächerlich.
Ich geh mal kurz pinkeln. So, wieder am Start. Ops. Haha. Untergefallen. Easykiller Battlefront 2 lässt mich auch kalt.
Ist auch wieder was, wo ich mich drüber aufregen könnte. Die Leute haben sich ja richtig gefreut damals.
Auf den ersten Teil. Da kam der erste Teil raus, war auch ganz okay, sah grafisch ziemlich gut aus.
Rest so, naja. Und dann haben sich viele Leute ja viel mehr Content gewünscht für Battlefront.
Haben sie sich einfach gedacht, nee, haben wir keinen Bock drauf, machen wir einfach Battlefront 2.
Und jetzt finde ich, sieht das Gameplay noch casual-lastiger aus.
Das ist halt Kate.
Mehr Kate-Shooter wie Battlefront kanns ja auch nicht. Wie die neuen Battlefront-Auflagen kanns ja kaum sein.
Wer hackt? Wer hackt? Wer soll hacken?
Ich hab jetzt nichts davon gemerkt bis jetzt.
Ja, fatal, komm mal zu uns ins Team. Wir müssen was bashen.
Müssen wir jetzt hier gewinnen.
Krasser Sniper.
Krasser Sniper, ne?
Oh nix, nix geht.
Was machen die ganzen Sniper hier?
Doch darfst du, ich switch dich.
Ich switch dich.
Ich darf das.
Ich hoffe, das bleibt dann auch.
Und jetzt sollte es dich auch nicht mehr switchen.
Weil ich...
Als Admin darf man das.
Jetzt müssen wir so ohren.
Hi, Krazy...
Krazy C.
Reds, please.
Wir müssen da einmal runterkommen und ordentlich aufräumen. Das gibt's doch nicht.
Nehmt mal nicht alle Sprint. Ja, das ist total beknackt.
Ähm...
Ah, hat schon geswitcht.
Alter!
Da geht's doch nicht.
Rätst mich halt auch mal einer.
Yikes.
So, mal gucken, ob wir es jetzt schaffen.
Was soll ich noch machen?
Yikes.
Ey.
Pusht, Leute. Pusht.
Pusht, macht sie platt. Pusht.
Pusherino.
In der Queue. Oh, das Server ist voll.
Krasser Chip.
Jetzt haben wir so nah dran.
Ich renne hier ein bisschen...
Offensichtlich, oder?
Du hast geflankt. Ich wollte es dir gerade sagen.
Was?
Oh, von der Seite. Fuck.
Ich...
Wir können den neuen Squad haben.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich will nicht tun.
Ähm...
Wie kann man...
Wie kann man Squads switchen, wenn alle voll sind?
Ähm...
Ich glaube, das funktioniert gerade nicht.
Retzen, retzen, retzen.
Wir brauchen...
Wir brauchen Tickets.
Go, go!
Fuck!
Knapp.
Uäh.
So, jetzt haben wir alle aktuellen Themen, was Konsolen und so betrifft, jetzt durchgekaut
mittlerweile.
Mm-mm.
Nee, Easykiller.
Kein Conquest.
bei einem Smartphone
stimmt da einfach so der Kosten-Nutzen
Aufwand nicht.
Und es sind ja auch
Einstiegspreise 1.300 Euro
eher. Wenn man das da noch
mit ordentlichem Speicherausbau und Geduld
kauft, dann sind wir wahrscheinlich eher bei 1.600.
Ups.
Holst du dir
dieses T-64-Schuh, Mac? Nö.
Ne.
Seh ich den Sinn von nicht.
Blankorino.
NAM.
Da. Da rechts. Was ist da rechts?
Fuck.
Oh oh. Oh oh.
Entschuldige.
Warum kann ich keine Befehle geben?
Weißt du?
Autsch. Red Splits.
Ne. Das ist ja übrigens das also
Weiß ich ob ich schon beantwortet habe.
Ja hab ich schon gesagt, dass ich mir das T-64-Schuh, Mac
nicht hole.
Was trifft mich da?
Was ist da los von der Seite?
Oh die holen wir uns.
Die recken wir jetzt.
Was?
Was hab ich denn da jetzt erwischt?
Der Typ?
Der Typ mit 6 Hells?
Da kriegen sie immer Schiss, die Helis.
Da kriegen sie immer Schiss.
Wo sie trifft.
Ich glaub wir sollten uns jetzt mal ordentlich aufstellen.
Weiter hinten.
Mach ihn platt, den Kack-Heli.
Oh.
Kommt ein Amtrak.
Ich hab Schiss.
Wo ist hier was?
Suche Gegner.
Oh ne, jetzt prallt es ausgerechnet auf mich.
Prallt es ausgerechnet da oben ran ab.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Kriegen wir das?
Nicht alle hintergehen.
Hab ich, hab ich grad ein Fallschirm gehört?
Krieg ich noch nen Retz?
Zurück.
PC hat kein Auto, ey.
Das ist richtig.
PC Masterware.
Oh fuck.
Ich glaub ich muss mal einen Engineer spawnen, den Amtrak killen.
Oder?
Muss ich?
gefallen für den follower leider kann ich wenig ausklingen
wenn ich jetzt eigentlich gerade vor
die arme aber die drücken schon ganz schön die gegner so die ersten drei da
oder die ersten vier die tröpfchen ganz schön rein
ich werde langsam echt
fünfeinhalb stunden reicht demnächst ich wollte nur ein bisschen battlefield
spielen nachdem er kreuz auf grün später so auf den sack gegangen ist weil es
immer geflasht ist haben wir von hinten
keine chance
oh nice ich bin gerad sparen jetzt mal voll
sollten wir mal weg
wo war der typ hier war doch gerade da war andere waffen ich spiele immer m4
16 ich kann auch im 16 spiel wenn euch das
lieber ist den game weiß jeder mittlerweile was die besten waffen sind
hier wird im prinzip nur noch guckt doch mal oben den killfield an so fast alles
im 16
ja wenn du noch die besten raffen gespielt
dass die super allround waffe
was ich wusste dass du jetzt um die ecke kommst kollege sie mit dem app
man sollte nicht so neben dem container stehen
das ding jetzt zu die fette geht eigentlich ganz gut
oder kommt er weg
stopp
Industries
появierte
Claro
RS
ROM
هو
Anne
Ravi
Moto
security audios
Momente
Sie müssten jetzt ja runterpuschen, dann bleibt ja nicht viel übrig.
Leute, ihr dürft nicht raus, wenn ihr rausgeht seid ihr im Arsch.
Man sieht's doch.
Hier geht's aber richtig hoch her.
Ich brauch Muni.
Haben wir hier noch ne Supply?
Moment, was? Wie haben die das da gelegt?
Fuck.
Knapp.
Du hast auf dem Hochhaus gesniped, das war Gullvor Forman, ne.
Doch, Gullvor Forman war das, oder?
Oder war das Sharky?
Die hatten glaube ich beide, beide Hochhäuser.
Ja, das war, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Stand das komplette Team gestackt hinter Kisten rum.
Das war aber, das war knapp.
Intens war das wirklich, intens.
Okay.
Gucken was jetzt kommt.
Jo, mir reicht's auch.
Wie?
Nochmal?
Wir haben gerade defended.
Was soll ich denn scheißen, warum soll ich denn scheißen?
Nochmal defenden?
Ne.
Oh ne, ich kann überhaupt mehr drauf jetzt.
Okay.
Ich hab jetzt 5 1⁄2 Stunden, bisschen mehr als 5 1⁄2 Stunden gestreamt.
So, das reicht für heute.
Ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen.
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao.